they are gold medal winning ice dancing
duo charlie white and meryl davis so how
well do they really know each other is
it possible rob that their dancing
partners know them even better possible
but we wanted to find out for sure so we
put them all to a little e.t test we
call who knows me best really not fair
17 years versus seven weeks but will his
skating or dancing partner know charlie
best where do i keep my gold medal
in your bag duffel bag oh backpack
what is my least favorite thing about
the costumes
if it's yellow she was right
who is my celebrity doppelganger
oh con a young call in birth these guys
said justin timberlake so i want to give
a shout out to e.t
for the compliment
a current justin timberlake or a 90s
justin 90s obviously
as for which partner knows meryl best
what is my favorite snack food
need your grain bar boom
i can't do it that quick it's like seven
in the morning
you should get this one max
what is my biggest fear
shelob coming to life and abducting you
kind of spiders yes max we talked about
this for like 15 minutes yes we have i'm
confused about the first thing you said
that's the lord of the rings reference
who
is my celebrity crush
we didn't talk about this yesterday
um
that canadian ryan uh gosselin no
well other ryan is the canadian ryan
reynolds reynolds that's like we can
share that at that point
we got half a point hey bud
nice reynolds gosling why do we have to
choose i'll go gosling okay tonight
marilyn maxx will be doing the tango
while charlie and shawna are doing the
cha-cha